fundamentally what we are talking about
is endowing machines with the power to
make decisions
that previously could only be made by
humanity
and we have to ask ourselves what kind
of decisions do we want
machines to make if we have any
aspiration
of these decisions reflecting the best
of humanity
we better focus on responsibility in all
of the pieces of it
you're listening to the microsoft
research podcast
a show that brings you closer to the
cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it i'm your
host gretchen huzinga
brad smith is the president of microsoft
and leads a team of more than 1400
employees in 56 countries
he plays a key role in spearheading the
company's work on critical issues
involving the intersection of technology
and society
in his spare time he's also an author we
were fortunate to catch up with brad
who late on a friday afternoon sat down
with me in the booth to talk about his
new book tools and weapons
the promise and the peril of the digital
age and revealed the top 10 tech policy
issues he believes will shape our own
centuries roaring 20s
he also gave us a peek inside the life
of a person the new york times has
described
as a de facto ambassador for the
technology industry at large
himself that and much more
on this episode of the microsoft
research podcast
[Music]
brad smith welcome to the podcast thank
you nice to be here
you're an unusual guest for us in the
booth as president of microsoft
you oversee a lot of stuff and you wear
a lot of hats
so let's kick things off by talking
about what gets brad smith up in the
morning
what does a day in the life of the
president of microsoft look like
i think what gets me up frankly is the
opportunity to
sit down and work hand in hand or at
least arm and arm
with you know researchers with engineers
with people focused on computer science
and data
and what it all means for the world
because that's really
in many ways my job it's the
intersection if you will between
engineering and the impact of data
and technology on the world today the
issues the challenges that all this
creates
i you know spend a lot of time
representing microsoft externally
i spend a lot of time working on our big
initiatives
internally i like to say that if there's
an intersection and there is between
engineering and the liberal arts
i'm the liberal arts side of the
intersection but i'm right
smack in the middle of it every day
i want to go there for a second because
we're looking at universities around
the country that have been responding to
the uptick in stem majors and the
downtick in humanities majors and
they're
responding financially they're closing
some departments and they're
consolidating some speak for a second
about the importance of the liberal arts
and humanities
road coming into this intersection i
think the
thing that people are missing today is
that more than ever technology is a
multi-disciplinary sport
this is an industry that was largely
built by engineers
researchers and developers and the like
and i grew up in it i've been at
microsoft for more than 26 years
but if you look at where technology is
going
i think everyone who majors in computer
science or data science
needs to take a dose of other courses in
the liberal arts
i think everybody who studies in the
liberal arts absolutely needs some
exposure to computer science to
data science to statistics and the like
but what we really need to recognize
is the teams that are going to do the
best work
who are going to solve the world's
greatest problems using technology
are almost always going to be
multi-disciplinary teams
people who've come from different
functions and different backgrounds
well a big chunk of what we're going to
talk about today is on the topic of
artificial intelligence or ai
and we have a lot of ground to cover but
before we get into the weeds i want to
start at a higher level
and look at ai through the lens of
responsibility
i think we all realize the power of ai
and many have begun to talk about things
like ethical ai and trusted ai but
you've chosen the word responsible
why i think it's important to have a
word that
encompasses more of what we're really
talking about
ethics play a fundamentally important
role
there are things that i think go beyond
ethics to some degree that are grounded
in the rule of law
in the recognition of human rights an
element of societal responsibility
fundamentally what we are talking about
is
endowing machines with the power to make
decisions
that previously could only be made by
humanity
and we have to ask ourselves what kind
of decisions do we want
machines to make if we have
any aspiration of these decisions
reflecting the best of humanity
we better focus on responsibility in all
of the pieces of it
well on that note you and your colleague
carol ann brown
who's microsoft senior director of
external relations and executive
communications
have a new book out called tools and
weapons just the title is fantastic
and it's evocative of the idea that
every new technology
comes as a package deal it's both a
blessing and a curse
so tell us what inspired you to write
this book at this time
i think two things inspired us to write
it
one is the ubiquitous nature of digital
technology in the world today
it really has become the fabric of our
lives our homes our communities our
societies
it is in some ways at the foundation of
every opportunity to make progress
technology is also part of every
challenge
that every community is facing that
really speaks to the tool
and the weapon that technology has
become
and we really felt that it was important
to reach a broader audience to bring
these issues to
life these issues are too important to
be left to people who work in tech
companies
by definition they're affecting everyone
and i think it's to some degree
incumbent
upon us who are closer to it to help
make the issues the facts if you will
more accessible to more people
in your work at microsoft and in tools
and weapons
you outline six core principles that you
suggest will guide us into this next
decade
and they provide the underpinning of
responsible ai which we've just alluded
to
so give us a brief overview of the
principles and why they're
important but also how you see them
playing out
in what i'll call an ai 5g quantum
computing cloud scale era
well first we at microsoft did develop
and publish our six
ethical principles in a way that's sort
of remarkable to me
this was only two years ago that we did
it this was a joint effort of really
people in microsoft research led by
harry shum and eric corvitz
and people in the part of the company
that i lead to work together
the six principles really cover first
fairness or the avoidance of bias
the need to protect privacy and security
the need to ensure that artificial
intelligence is safe and reliable
the need to ensure that it's inclusive i
will say for all people and perhaps with
a special eye towards the billion people
on the planet
who have some sort of disability that
adds up to four those four principles
really
sit on two others that are foundational
for all of them
one is transparency the notion that
people can't understand
or have confidence in the fulfillment of
these principles unless there is a level
of transparency
and then there is the principle that i
think is the bedrock of them all
accountability the notion that machines
must remain accountable
to people the principle that the people
who create
this technology must remain accountable
to society as a whole
that adds up to the six and what i think
is interesting in part
is that this set of principles or other
principles like them
are really spreading around the world i
think to some degree
microsoft's principles influenced others
certainly to some degree other people's
work influenced us
but mostly and i think it's encouraging
people are tending to think in fairly
similar ways and you see a consensus
emerging more or less almost organically
that's encouraging
how do you think how do you wrap your
brain around the fact that
while you and others can say these are
the things we're
aiming for you've got all these other
players and actors in the world that may
or may not be
as eager to follow those as you well i
think that
really points to two very important
dimensions
i'll just call it the state of
responsible ai in the world today
the first is even those of us who
embrace these principles have to
recognize
that being able to articulate them is
not sufficient
to operationalize them and so the
biggest challenge whether you're talking
about microsoft or any institution in
the world today
is really to figure out how to take its
commitment to principles
and turn them into something that is
real every day
and that requires going from principles
to policies
you need to implement these policies in
a series of standards
things like research or development
guidelines you need to put in place
training programs for employees
you have to have the capability to
measure and monitor whether they're
being pursued
you need compliance systems you need to
build all of that
and we need to do it in a case like
microsoft literally
at a global scale and i don't think
anyone should
underestimate just the magnitude of that
challenge
and then by the way you have the second
what do you do about people who say
that's very nice
i don't care um i'm not going to be
principled or i'm not going to sign on
for that principle i'm
going to use artificial intelligence in
ways that are going to do societal
damage
and i think this is where public policy
and the law kicks in
ultimately the only way to ensure that
everyone is ethical or
is accountable for some ethical standard
is to take the ethical principles that
we want to apply universally
and enact them into law every year you
and your team
while we're on the topic of lists
identify 10 top tech issues
that you predict will be important for
the coming year and when it's a
beautiful year like 20 20
for the coming decade as you've said in
your book tools and weapons
technical innovation isn't going to slow
down so the pace of the work around it
has to speed up
give us an overview of the lists you've
got this year for the decade of our own
roaring 20s as it were and your thoughts
on how people doing the technical work
as well as the people doing the other
work might help address them and do so
at the speed of technology
we really found it helpful to create our
top 10 list this year this is something
that carol anne brown and i have done
for a few years in a row
and you know having then written the
book and been out
talking with people about the book we
took the conversations and
frankly everything we were hearing from
other people took a step back and said
well it's the 2020s
let's just not focus on 10 issues for
the year
let's think about 10 issues for the
decade yeah and
they tended to fall into i would say you
know four buckets the first an issue all
of its own but a bucket
completely uh on its own is
sustainability
just because we see climate as such an
important issue and it's going to
reshape everything
including technology right second we
have
issues of fundamental importance around
trust
around privacy security digital safety
responsible ai
third we see huge issues around
geopolitics
whether it's the relationship between
the united states and china
or the focus on digital sovereignty
especially in countries in europe
and finally there's really the role of
technology in
inequality we talk a lot about income
inequality
you see technology playing into that
especially in the context
of internet inequality some people have
broadband some don't
skills or educational inequality
especially access to digital skills
housing inequality in cities like
seattle or san francisco where the tech
sector is fueling
a rise in housing prices so when you
take you know the future of the planet
our ability to trust technology the
geopolitics of technology
and you know technology fueled
inequality
it's going to be quite a decade the the
roaring 20s may be
pretty roaring i think is one way to
think about it
you know you're a lawyer and the thing
that
seems to be lagging the most in my mind
and i may not be alone
is that the law hasn't caught up to
technology
what kinds of things are happening in
the sort of political and legal
structures
around we've seen gdpr in europe and and
some of the other
sort of thinking forward what's
happening elsewise in this arena
well the basic thesis of our book is
that tech
companies need to step up and do more
and governments need to start moving
faster yeah
we are starting to see governments move
faster
probably first and foremost in i'll say
brussels and beijing
those are the two places where
regulation tends to move the fastest
we're seeing it in other places i think
it'll be fascinating to see what unfolds
in london
now that the united kingdom is really
its own regulatory power if you will
we will see more momentum in washington
dc
already we're seeing it at the state
level in the united states
we're seeing california be a leader in
the united states around privacy
so i think it's very clear that by the
end of this decade
technology is going to be more regulated
than it is today
and that will be good and that will
create challenges for all of us who work
with it
well and the fact that it has to i mean
we you've got things that
people would say we don't even know what
to do with this in a court
right one of the points we've made
is that in so many respects digital
technology has gone
unregulated for probably a longer period
of time than
any important technology in the period
of time say since the 1850s
compared to the automobile or airplanes
for example
everything that resulted from the
combustion engine we saw
more regulation or just think about the
world in which we live
foods drugs you know cars today
they're all regulated by health and
safety standards and yet
digital technology is not and yeah i
think it's
overdue you know it doesn't mean that
regulators should be thoughtless or
uninformed or
failed to think about balance but we do
need a regulatory floor and i think it's
right to recognize that
right and even the things you mention
these are all things that have imminent
harm potential
if something goes wrong and i think
we're just starting to figure out that
there's
potential imminent harms with these
technologies
i think that is true and i think that
you know by 2030
in so many ways an automobile is going
to be a computer on wheels
an airplane is going to be a computer
with wings but fundamentally computers
digital technology ai
will raise many of these issues even if
they're in a box that's standing still
well one of the biggest fears that
people have about ai aside from
sensational predictions
in the popular press is a grouping of
topics that you've mentioned
privacy safety and security in an ai
world we've talked a bit about the what
of these concerns but i want you to talk
a little bit about the what now
well i think the first question for
anybody who works in the technology
field as a researcher a developer or
designer
is actually to think hard about what
these issues mean
for the products that people want to
create what does it mean to have privacy
by design to have digital safety by
design
to have responsible ai by design they
have cyber security by design
all of these are design fields that have
started to really take off and in many
respects they're maturing rapidly
in many respects i think those of us who
are connected with the creation
or the research advances in the
technology
are absolutely in the best position to
bring innovation
to the protection of people that will be
essential
and then if you look beyond that all of
us are users of technology
we're all consumers increasingly there
are many features in
popular products consumer products
business services and the like
that do protect privacy certainly they
protect security
and the question is whether as consumers
we want to use them
and you know for all of us who care
about these causes i think there is some
real benefit to using them and
frankly helping to give a boost for the
kind of usage that will help drive
improvements right interestingly and
i've had some other researchers in the
booth who've talked about these privacy
and security and safety issues
a lot of technology is binary you either
want to use the app and so you agree to
everything
or you say no and sorry you can't use
the app
so is there any move towards controls on
the part of
consumers and users in technology to say
hey it's not just binary you can have
this about me but you can't have that
i think the answer is no and yes
no i mean some services are binary but
increasingly
you look at an app on a phone and you
think about something like the location
service
there's three choices you can never use
the location service
you can always have the location service
on even when the app itself is not
running
or you can say the location service can
locate me but only when i'm using the
app
and the first thing i would say is if
you want to protect your privacy you can
go to that middle
level and only have the location service
know where you are when you actually
want the app to do something for you
right
but i would then actually step back and
look much more broadly
there's a lot to what you say in
suggesting that
we don't have as much choice as
consumers as we might like
so what do we do i've had vibrant
debates
in silicon valley where some in the tech
sector have said look
the fact that people are not turning
away from this app or another
means that people fundamentally don't
care about privacy
i believe they do care but people want
to continue to use these services
and where you see them manifesting their
opinion
is actually the public opinion that is
increasingly shaping the views of
government officials
the fact that california passed a
sweeping privacy law
after it had enough signatures to go on
the ballot
after the polling showed it would be
passed overwhelmingly
i believe says people do care they want
to have their privacy
protected and they want to be able to
use the service
they want both in your book and
elsewhere
you also talk about the positive things
that
we're seeing as a result of advances in
technology and one of the best things
about ai is its ability to democratize
and improve areas like medicine and
accessibility in the environment
so just in 2020 so far it's been a busy
january for you brad
you've led two big announcements for the
company one is
on microsoft's carbon negative by 2030
initiative
yes to say it right and another is the
launch of ai for health
with peter lee from microsoft research
here both are part of your ai for good
program so tell us a little bit more
about these announcements and
why they're important to microsoft's
larger mission
in developing technology they were both
really important and in my view exciting
steps for
microsoft to take our carbon
announcement i think is
not just important to microsoft i hope
it is something
that can be part of an ongoing broader
movement
that we're clearly seeing every day that
is sweeping around the world
moving across the business community and
really mobilizing
companies to do more to address carbon
and climate issues
it took a huge amount of work to bring
together every part of microsoft
to really make that announcement
possible and it
took a lot of iteration to sort of get
to a point where we could have the
ambition that was as high as i felt we
needed
but also the rigor of a plan that would
give us confidence that the goals could
be met
it speaks powerfully to the role of
digital technology in part
because we have these huge goals as you
mentioned to be carbon negative by 2030
to
in effect go back in time and remove by
2050 all the carbon that microsoft has
emitted since its
founding in 1975. and part of this
goes to the heart of more renewable
energy for our data centers
more efficiency for our data centers a
variety of other steps where digital
technology digital transformation uh
will just be fundamental to not just
microsoft's own direct carbon reductions
but also across our supply chain our
value chain
so digital technology is i think a
foundational tool
for helping to address the world's
climate needs
and at the same time that we hopefully
have a planet that
is habitable in the right kind of way
we can also spread better health for the
human population
and this is where the ai for health
initiative that really peter lee and
then john cahan from the data science
side
have been at the heart of leading and
there are so many areas where
it's now clear that data and artificial
intelligence
can help lead to breakthroughs
breakthroughs in
helping us find cures for diseases
helping us understand the distribution
of if you will
health among different populations
helping us bring
better health to broader populations
ai is in a sense at the heart of
everything in the world today
so it makes sense that as we've been
expanding our own ai for good
efforts we now have five pillars we
started with ai for earth
we went to ai for accessibility ai for
humanitarian action
ai for cultural heritage and now ai for
health
it is exciting to see how many different
problems ai can help us address
i think what it really points to and i
think it's an interesting
aspect of all of this is again the
multi-disciplinary
nature of technology so much i believe
of the cutting edge of research
is not just within a field but
the ai for earth work is a great example
of this at microsoft
we have a team that consists of computer
scientists
and data scientists and environmental
and you can take the first two and add
in a third discipline from a broad list
of disciplines
and if you can get people working
together you can probably do some good
for the world
[Music]
well microsoft isn't the only one in the
ai game it's at the forefront of every
major tech company
and more importantly the forefront of
many nation states now
as president of this company i'd like to
know how you position
microsoft in this very large arena and
how you view the company's role
in the ai world what's microsoft's
vision in terms of
leadership in ai both inside the company
and outside
there are two things that come together
that i think are critically important
the first is microsoft's grounding for
all of us who work here
in our mission you know it really is a
mission
to empower other people other
organizations
all around the world to use technology
including ai to achieve more
now what that means put in that context
is a couple of key things one is our
mission really is
universal i mean we're trying to create
technology that people
can use around the world to better
themselves and their communities
one of the things that means is that we
want to democratize technology we want
to democratize access to it
i don't think that any of us should want
a future
where the secrets or the wealth of ai
resides just in a couple of countries
companies
or companies absolutely i think we
should think of it more like electricity
electricity has spread around the world
and a country
benefited from it mostly based on how
quickly it
adopted it right and spread it to its
rural communities and the like that's
what we should want of ai
but there is a second dimension that is
also to some degree at odds with the
notion of providing this technology to
anyone who wants it to do with it
whatever they choose
it goes back to these principles and i
would
argue that those principles are even
implicit
in our mission you can't empower people
if you can't protect them if you can't
keep them safe
so there are certain use cases that we
won't
allow for our technology at times it
means there are certain countries
where we won't be comfortable providing
the full range of services
and this is a more complicated world it
is
in some ways vastly more complicated
than the world of producing microsoft
word
and letting anybody use it knowing that
somebody would
create a work that would get the nobel
prize in literature
and someone else would write something
truly horrible
but we created the tool and we were not
responsible for whether somebody turned
it into a weapon if you will
because we couldn't control that but in
a world where ai runs as a service in a
data center from the cloud
you can impose more controls and i think
that's one of the reasons that
governments and
the public is expecting more of tech
companies
they expect us to do more because we
can't and should
so along those lines you've said that
microsoft isn't planning to deliver ai
in a big box but rather
deliver the building blocks of ai so
anyone can build ai systems
obviously with some caveats there since
we're sitting here in the heart of
microsoft research
i want to get your take on what those
building blocks
are and the role of research in
delivering them well i think it's a
really great question and i see it
not just at a place like microsoft
research but i've also
served as a trustee at princeton
university for a number of years
and i would say two things one is you
see
in computer science departments or you
see in
other departments that are really you
know at the foundation for data science
certain ongoing opportunities for
advances
at the basic research level and these
are
in many ways fields that people here at
msr and elsewhere have been
heavily involved for not just years but
decades
things like you know computer vision
things like
speech recognition almost anything
relating to machine learning
you know so you have a lot of these
fields that are just moving forward very
quickly
but at the same time i think so much of
the most
important work is actually very
multi-disciplinary
certainly at a place like princeton you
have the opportunity to work
and see you know some of the issues in
the environmental field again
or micro biology i see issues that
we're working on microsoft and princeton
together around so-called programmable
biology
and i think that is such a defining part
of the future
it's why i'm always excited about the
fact that at microsoft
we have a lot of people who have phds in
computer science or data science
and we have a growing number of people
who have phds
in other fields and then we work to
bring them together and the same thing
is happening at universities
well brad we've reached the part of the
podcast where i always ask the guests to
get real and
answer what could possibly go wrong a
good part of your professional career
has been dealing with things that go
wrong
in a court of law and you're a veteran
at the what keeps you up at night
question so as a leader of one of the
most well-known tech companies on the
planet you have to consider every single
day the potential downsides of every
technology that your company's putting
out there
so what keeps brad smith up at night and
how does he mobilize a company like
microsoft to help him sleep better
i think fundamentally the thing that i
worry about the most
is the weaponization of the technology
that we create
it can be weaponized in very specific
scenarios
say something like facial recognition to
stop people from
peacefully assembling in a city square
it can be weaponized because of the
risks of bias by a police force that's
not well trained
i worry that data
and data centers can be accessed by
governments
to monitor people on a scale
that you know has been well imagined it
was written about 70 years ago
in the book 1984 but now it can become a
reality
i think the most natural thing for any
creative company to do
is to just keep creating more products
and keep selling them to anyone who will
buy them and yet if you want to be
principled if you want to
do good if you want to be responsible
you have to be able to say no no
that is not something we want to create
no that is not something we want to sell
for that particular use to that
particular user
and it takes an enormous amount of
discipline self-discipline and business
process
to ensure that an organization
especially one operating at a global
scale
will avoid falling into those traps
that's one of the things that keeps me
up
at night wanting to make sure that we at
this company
don't fall prey to that kind of problem
you know the researchers that answer
this question can rarely go into those
weeds
they're making the things a person like
you can
upstream is where the company and or the
leadership decides
how we're going to be as a company one
of the things that gives me great hope
and encouragement is that i find that
our employees do care about it and want
us to do the right thing
and i've been so encouraged even
typically when i've run into an account
team
that might have been working for months
to sell something and then they're told
they can't but they
really do get it but it does require
that we
all remember that we have to stay
constantly focused on this
you can say you're principled but if at
the end of the day you'll do every deal
that can be done
then the only principle you're really
upholding is a principle that you'll do
every deal that can be done and it ends
up swallowing everything else
brad you have small town midwestern
routes and a decidedly non-technical
background
give us a brief history of brad smith
how did your early life shape who and
what you are today
and how did you gravitate from history
to high tech
well i was really fortunate i like to
joke that i grew up in a middle-income
family in the middle of the country with
the last name smith the most common name
in the middle of the phone book almost
literally
um but out of all of that i came out of
wisconsin was really lucky uh
to go to princeton and you know
work my way and get scholarships on my
way through college
and that was one of the places that
introduced me to technology
and technology policy issues well i was
a student
by my junior year i had literally
graduated from delivering newspapers in
the morning and serving
food in the cafeteria in the evening to
having a job working for the
university's director of government
affairs
wow i was just a student assistant it
was nothing terribly grand
but the issues that we got to work on
were fundamentally science and
technology policy issues
things like federal support for basic
research things like the
federal government's support for plasma
physics
fusion research where princeton did and
still does have a national laboratory
so that really awakened my interest in
this intersection between
technology and policy and then a few
years later there was this new thing
coming out on the market called a
personal computer
and as somebody who was going through
law school somebody who had to do a lot
of writing i looked at this and i got
quite excited
both because of sort of the technical
technology gadget
side but also i looked at it and said up
and i can write faster and better if i
have this
and then play games as well and it
turned out that all that was true
[Laughter]
so how did you end up working for the
company that makes personal computers
well in a sense it all was a sort of
continuous journey
i bought that first personal computer
my wife and i were both law students
loved it so much that then my first job
after law school was working in the
federal courthouse for a federal judge
in manhattan
and so i literally took the equivalent
of 10 of my
annual salary and bought a new improved
personal computer
took it into the courthouse where there
had not been
and there were not pcs and then applied
for a job in the law firm
in washington dc and when i got the
offer i said i would only accept it if
they would give me a pc on my desk
happily they said yes it was such an
unusual request for someone to make at
that time
that everybody in this large law firm of
about 250 lawyers said
there's this weird kid on the eighth
floor who
seems to know something about computers
and so
i had an opportunity arise to start to
do legal work for microsoft
i loved it so much when they asked me to
join the company in 1993
i said yes it was supposed to be a
two-year leave of absence i had just
become a partner at the law firm
and that was more than 26 years ago and
here you are now
president of the mothership
it's something right yes oh
well this has been fantastic brad at the
end of every podcast i asked my guest to
share some insight or wisdom with our
listeners and usually they're seasoned
researchers at msr speaking to some
version of their grad school self
but you're in a unique position to offer
advice from a different perspective
so what would you say to our audience
many of whom are the very people
who will shape the technology that will
shape our world for the decades to come
i would say three things one always push
the edge of the envelope
without quite busting the entire door
down
because that's when you end up you know
fraying relationships and finding it
more difficult to get things done
but push the edge of the envelope have
confidence in yourself
and take those creative ideas within you
and pursue them
the second thing i would say is balance
that with a sense of humility
i actually think that the great
superpower that we have in the nadella
years here at microsoft and something
that i'm
absolutely passionate about is what i'll
call the power of humility
i like to joke across microsoft no one
ever died of humility
but it really helps you stay curious
it helps you ask other people
good questions it encourages you to
listen and not just
talk and stay focused on
getting better and finally i would say
at the end of the day
it's great to be smart it's great to be
successful but it's better to be honest
to have a sense of integrity to me the
favorite
story perhaps that carol and i tell in
the book is one that involved me
personally
and it was a story where we had stated
publicly to our customers that we would
sue the federal government if the
government came
asking for their data without in this
case organizations being allowed to know
and you know when our litigators came
and said we shouldn't pursue this case
because
we were likely to lose it was likely to
be expensive and painful
i said look i i'd rather be a loser than
a liar
it's okay to lose everybody does
sometimes and then you bounce back
but if you lie if you sacrifice your
integrity
i do think you pay a price for that for
a very long
time so be ambitious
be humble be honest it's a good recipe
it serves people well
i think that needs to be on a bumper
sticker
i'll work on shortening it even more
yeah
brad smith thank you so much for joining
us today
it's been a real treat thank you thanks
for having me
[Music]
to learn more about the research behind
the tools and the researchers who do it
visit microsoft.com research
you